i asked you to open up a fresh
spreadsheet for me and this is what i
would like you to make it look like
it's very very similar to the previous
one right there's going to be a year
there's going to be an interest
calculation but the subtle difference is
we're going to have a repayment not a
payment
so when you hear the word repayment what
does that instantly tell you
yeah i'm paying off repeatedly
something that i've borrowed right does
that make sense okay so i've borrowed a
huge amount or someone has you'll see it
in a second and we're trying to get rid
of this debt
okay so here are three columns
if you like just like before you can
take these two columns which are clearly
going to have amounts of money in them
and you can use the um you can use the
dollar sign to format that so that it's
a currency i've already done that for
mine
so once you've got your three columns
set up let's start to have a look at
this
question uh up there in the top left
this person loam low loamy loam took out
a loan
with some bizarrely named credit union
it's 15 thousand dollars
to be repaid in 15 equal annual
installments
uh it gives you the amount the size of
each installment it tells you it's on
the first of april each year and then
they tell you an interest rate what is
the interest rate
seven percent per annum how often does a
compound
because no other information is provided
you can assume it's
per annum right if they wanted it to be
per month they'd have to tell you yeah
thumbs up now you can see just like
before there's this long series of
questions here right we're not going to
worry about them too much
we're just going to use the initial
information in the question
to set up our model and just like before
we can then use our model to answer
whatever questions they throw at us
thumbs up
now in the previous one and i'll show
you it just here they gave us a specific
year it's like oh it starts in 2021
right or 2005 or what it happens to be
have a look at this question
do they tell you when it starts
not precisely i mean they tell you they
tell you first of april
but they're like what time period is
this i have no idea
right so yeah we can use that up for
ourselves so
rather than define it as like 2001 or
this right i'm just gonna say
year one year two year three now
as has been suggested before i'm
actually going to start at year 0.
it's going to be really helpful for us
to do this you'll see why okay
when it says repayment there what i mean
is
the repayment that occurs how does that
impact the amount that is
actually owing okay now in year zero no
repayments have actually happened yet
so how much do i owe before any
repayments have been made
it's in the question have a look zero
oh think think i've just taken out a
loan right it's
15 000. that's how much i
owe right now here's the thing right you
know
interest calculations yeah interest
calculations in the previous
question with superannuation the
interest calculation happened
i'm just going to go over to it it
happened at the end of the year
right we had to have our money in there
for like 12 months before they would pay
us
a cent does that make sense right but
guess what
when you're borrowing money the bank's
like
hey hold on a second it's to my
advantage
i'm the bank now right it's to my
advantage if i charge you
interest earlier right like the sooner i
charge you interest the more money i
make
so guess what they do before you've made
any repayments
they already charge you interest okay
you're like what
what jerks i'll just pay earlier right
well they'll just charge you earlier as
well
so therefore you can see year zero no
payment has happened
but they're going to charge you interest
because the bank always wins okay
so how do we do this we're going to take
the amount that was owing
there it is right there and we're going
to
add on the interest so i'm going to
multiply by well what am i going to
multiply by
one point zero seven
so what this does is it captures the
amount that's already there that's the
one
and then it adds on the interest
calculation that's the 0.07 are you with
me
okay so we hit enter you're like this is
not looking good i haven't done anything
this thing's already going up okay
but thankfully i'm gonna go to year one
i'm gonna
take the previous year and add one
and now my repayments are going to begin
did you have a question you're okay
what is through payment again
it's in the question right have a look
what what is the repayment it's this
awkward number here
right okay yeah yeah okay so
i'm going to take whatever i owed before
that's that figure there and because i'm
making a repayment i'm reducing how much
is owed right so remember last time i
was adding on
my superannuation is getting bigger and
bigger and bigger i don't want this to
get bigger and bigger and bigger
i want to get smaller and smaller and
smaller so that's why i've got a minus
sign
i'm subtracting are you with me okay
what's the thing i'm subtracting again
what quantity
look look at the quantity it's 1 6
four six and 92 cents that's my
repayment does that make sense okay so i
hit
enter so this is how much i owe
after having made my first repayment but
what does the bank do
because they're they're not in this for
charity they're in this to make a profit
they're going to charge us interest
right now thankfully we already know how
to charge
interest it's in this uh this cell right
here
yeah so i don't need to retype this i'm
just going to copy it and i'm going to
paste it down are you following so far
let's go ahead and copy and then
paste
how's it looking does that make sense
it's looking okay so far
all right now i just do want to point
out right
it's looking okay mathematically but
financially
i'm like a little bit depressed right
because i started out owing fifteen
thousand dollars
i've made a repayment but i owe more
than i started
at the beginning right so like this is
not going well for me that's why my
repayment has to be fairly
substantial okay now what's great is
see all of these um these cells right
i've set them up already we've done all
the hard work that i can just do this
recursive thing do it over and over
again
and i should get the next year i'm going
to copy all three cells
and i'm going to pay it down to the next
row
you with me yeah and yes mo you've
already got down to row 15 that's great
so you can just double check this is the
repayment
i minus 1 646.92
repayments done and then i go over to
the other one
and there's the interest calculation
goes up by seven percent
okay and for the first time i actually
owe less than what i started with but at
least i'm making progress you see this
okay
now what's great is the question itself
tells us how long this is supposed to go
for
how many years do i do this 15 years
right
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
and if you didn't know this before
when you highlight these cells that you
want to copy and paste down
if you are very careful with your cursor
you might notice in the bottom right
hand corner there's a little
little sort of blob there you can put
onto
if you look really closely your cursor
will change color and you can drag this
down
if you look closely you'll see i'm
holding down my cursor
and it'll go down as far as you want it
to i want it to get at 15 right
so i'll just keep going a little further
okay now i've gotten down to year 15.
um raise your hand if like me you use
the the
currency formatting on your cells did
you use currency formatting yep okay
fantastic thank you guys now
what you'll notice is if you've done
that yours should look exactly like mine
you can see
there's these figures in brackets right
what that's
doing is it's saying oh that's negative
right you've actually gone past you
don't owe anything anymore or you're
actually in credit at this point
okay so it checks out after 15 years
we have paid off the entire loan does
that make sense
okay now you can go back to the question
and you can see say it again
um well fast or slow kind of depends on
how long you wanted to go for right i'll
give you an example my hex debt
right that's how much i have to pay the
government back
for my university fees right it's in my
interest to pay that off as
slow as possible because it's a very low
interest loan
right the government's hardly charging
me anything for that so even though it's
like oh it sounds bad to be
in debt i actually make more money
holding on to that money and putting it
in the bank than i make by paying it off
and getting rid of the debt um i've
already paid off mine completely because
um the government forces you at a
certain point but you know
i want to pay it off as slow as possible
so slow and fast just depends on what
you want
your small interest rate will happen on
a large amount of money therefore you're
paying more
right so i'll give you i'll just give
you a very very uh
exaggerated example of it okay just
imagine you had
a hundred dollars are you like what
should i do with this a hundred dollars
i could use this 100 to pay off my debt
that i've got
or i could put my 100 in the bank and i
can earn interest right
now which one you choose depends
entirely on
how bad the debt is and how good the
interest is right
think about this if i'm getting charged
on this debt
at a really high amount right then it's
in my interest to get rid of that debt
fast does that make sense
classic example credit card debt credit
card debt's usually charged at like 20
to 25
20 to 25 right so
don't use your credit card for credit
okay if i've got 100
credit card debt pay that off straight
away right
your bank account will never pay you 20
or 25 interest it might pay you like
three or four
right so what you gain here isn't as
good as what you can get rid of here
does that make sense
okay however hex that's actually very
very low i can't remember because i paid
off a while ago but
it's debt is not 20 or 25 it's like one
or two it's very small
right so the advantage i get by paying
that off is also
quite small it's better for me to
actually invest that in something else
even putting it in the bank right if my
bank account will give me four percent
interest
and my hex debts are two percent it's
better to keep that debt
because this bank account is actually
earning me more interest than i'm losing
from
my hex debt okay so you've got to look
carefully at what the numbers are
make sense